i was raised as a catholic but i
wouldn't really describe myself as
religious today i had never heard of
things like mega churches or
televangelism or the prosperity gospel
that was until i stumbled across an
infamous interview how are you sir we'd
just like to ask you about why you don't
want to fly commercial you've got this
journalist that is confronting this guy
called kenneth copeland you said that
you don't like to fly commercial because
you don't want to get into a tube with a
bunch of demons do you really believe
that human beings are demons no i do not
and don't you ever say i did get in a
long tube with a bunch of demons we
wrestle not
with flesh and blood
but principalities and powers copeland
is being confronted about his purchase
of a gulfstream jet and it turns out
that that jet is just one of a fleet of
jets that he owns along with a boathouse
a mansion and his very own airport this
is a preacher that is supposedly worth
hundreds of millions of dollars with an
enormous following and you're telling me
that he is just one of many
this entire thing is a rabbit hole
pastor what is now the largest church in
america a weekly sermon watched by more
than 10 million viewers on television
the apostles were businessmen they were
rich men had plenty of money i'm going
to show you that jesus was a wealthy man
that pretty much one of my shameless
costs most people's house i got 22
chandeliers in the house they're
extremely green they don't need matches
they don't need jets god
told me to have that plane
any religious leader who speaks the word
of god who has more than one suit while
someone has no clothes is a cop-out yeah
you know larry i just don't see it that
way for 54 million dollars i want you to
imagine how many people could be fed
how many homeless could have places to
sleep
the fresh swell of all fresh fresh fresh
fresh fries
televangelism is still thriving
if you were willing to pay the price you
could talk directly to god
[Music]
when i remember my own personal
experiences inside of a church
what comes to mind was definitely not
this
at times it's like a concert and when
the preachers come to preach it's like a
celebrity has just taken to the stage
everyone is worshiping together they're
smiling they're joined in their faith
and devotion what we're witnessing is
something called a mega church by
definition a mega church is just a
church that has a larger than average
congregation normally of 2 000 members
or above but when we think of
spirituality or forms of it there's
normally a distinction between spiritual
duty and materialistic desires now i'm
not a theologian and i'm not going to
pretend to be one but even i remember
verses from the bible when it came to
wealth and building riches that it
wasn't viewed favorably upon but if my
memory is correct
then what was i witnessing in this
interview with copeland and moreover
some of these preachers
so you've got this preacher kenneth
copeland who founded the kenneth
copeland ministries along with his wife
gloria they own a 7 million home a fleet
of jets and their eagle mountain
international church has a membership in
the thousands not to mention their
television and online broadcasting then
there's jesse duplantis who sat with
copeland as they both justified their
purchases of private jets and then the
second one i purchased was in january
2004
benny hinn who claims to be able to
perform miracles who fills up stadiums
and broadcast it on networks worldwide
i'll release it
joel osteen a very popular figure
especially in houston texas where his
church resides who's authored books that
have been on new york times bestsellers
as well as hosting church services with
celebrities like kanye west creflo's
dollar who has created fundraisers for
his private jets whose ministry owns two
rolls-royces and expensive real estate
taboo god is the gateway to the world of
wealth there's this instagram page which
is called preachers and sneakers and
it's literally just preachers next to
the cost of the clothing that they are
wearing something something just isn't
right i keep asking myself how right how
is it possible to be this braggadocious
about your wealth as a preacher and have
your followers who not only are okay
with it but help to fund it
and that was when i found out about the
prosperity gospel
what we're looking at is a movement that
has seemingly found its way inside of
america's biggest mega churches and
being taught by its biggest preachers
the word of faith movement is its name
and its teachings are often referred to
as the prosperity gospel it's a simple
idea god wants you to be prosperous
through your finances your health your
marriage and relationships in fact those
are things that belong to you through
your faith if you are willing to receive
it the prosperity gospel often refers to
its believers as little gods the idea
being that we were made in the image of
god and therefore possess a level of
divinity within us that allows us to
bring into existence the prosperity that
we've been promised you are
gods little g you are god's because you
came from god and your dna and jesus dna
are exact you're exactly like
it sounds
amazing
so how do i earn this prosperity how do
i access this divine power that i
supposedly have
well
it starts with your faith but if you'll
stay in faith there will come a point
where god will say enough is enough is
payback time bible says i know you love
the lord so you
you qualify for for prosperity
next you have the act of tithing the
initial concept of tithing was this idea
that you give one tenth of your wealth
in some way shape or form to a religious
organization most houses of worship are
going to rely on the donation of their
congregation in order to continue their
operations especially mega churches it's
kind of like giving to a charity but
tithing through the teachings of the
prosperity gospel
introduces a
should we call it a plot twist tithing
lays the foundation for financial
success and abundance
tithing is the way
for recession or depression to bypass
you here stephanie from maryland writes
i sent him my first hoots offering two
weeks later i received watch this two
thousand four hundred dollars so now it
isn't just about donating your money to
a church it becomes a case where you're
exchanging your money in return for
actual prosperity you'll often hear some
of these prosperity preachers refer to
it as sowing your seed the implication
is pretty obvious to anyone who is
watching no you give us some of your
money and in return that value will be
given back to you in some way shape or
form it's the harvest i want you to go
to the phone
or online
and sow a seed now
remember somebody's son is gonna be set
free from alcohol because of your
thousand dollars and i'm going to ask
you to sew an exceptional and uncommon
seat of one thousand dollars click on
that donation button to sew 1 144
so god has given you the harvest and the
harvest off the seeds you've sown you
can't expect a harvest if you don't sow
seed spiritual
physical or financial
it's surreal
and it generates a lot of money
on january the 12th of 2008 kenneth
copeland ministries took possession of a
gulfstream jet which was funded all
thanks to the donors of his church in
fact kcm wrote a blog post thanking
their followers for helping them quote
harvest the gulf stream but our work is
not done to which the blog then proceeds
to remind their followers that they
still need 17 million more dollars which
will be used for the quote sewing
towards the construction of a new hangar
upgrading the existing runway and
purchasing special gulf stream
maintenance equipment or how about
creflo dollar's infamous sermon to which
he tells his congregation to help him
fundraise towards a private jet all to
the response of cheers and applause from
the audience if i want to believe god
for a 65 million dollar plane you cannot
stop me you cannot stop me from dreaming
see copeland and dollars please for
money they're not met with criticism and
backlash from their congregation
it's celebrated and prosperity preachers
will obviously say that this aids in
their quest to spread their message
across to different countries if i flew
commercial
i'd have to stop 65 percent of what i'm
doing conveniently that message
obviously allows them to make even more
donations but these preachers they don't
just live lavish right they they put it
on full display do you think jesus
christ would roll around in a rolls
royce uh i think he would let's get a
close-up of gloria's ring where am i
looking right here you fly in a private
plane yes i'm you're staying right now
one of the fanciest hotels i am you wear
nice very nice clothing so
[Applause]
[Music]
the wealth of these preachers they're
not seen as gross or hypocritical in
fact they're seen of proof that the
teachings work it's seen as them
actually practicing what they preach the
extravagant lifestyle that's not a
mistake or a flaw
it's a feature of the prosperity gospel
many of these preachers will say that
the funds that they received are used
only for ministry purposes osteen for
example says that he doesn't receive any
salary from his ministry and all the
money he makes comes from his book sales
look in some ways i don't really care if
a ministry wants to buy a private jet it
looks optically hypocritical but i'd
rather let theologians argue over the
contradictions that those actions have
with actual religious texts i'm more
interested in how the money is generated
and it doesn't get more unethical of a
promise than it does with the prosperity
gospel if you're accustomed of giving 10
go to twenty go up to seventy eighty a
hundred raise that amount and watch what
god will do because don't you stop
sewing offerings well they won't let us
go to church well email it in there text
give or something you get that tithe in
that church you get that offering in
that church and then you go home and you
do what we're supposed to do
this idea is no different than the law
of attraction and manifestation circles
that claim that you can use your mind to
manifest any desire that you want in
fact it's been argued that the
prosperity theology does have similar
roots to the new thought philosophy that
became popular in america in the 19th
century when i look at osteen for
example i don't necessarily see a
preacher i see someone who's more akin
to a self-help motivational speaker that
uses god as a proxy
[Music]
[Applause]
new york times bestseller book your best
life now which is filled with all of
these kinds of ideas so here's a quote
from the very first chapter enlarging
your vision it's not god's lack of
resources or your lack of talent that
prevents you from prospering your own
wrong thinking can keep you from god's
best
and the book is riddled with these
similar messages of becoming what you
believe and the power of your words it's
a book like many others in the self-help
genre the connection isn't really that
hard to see
but it's this sowing your seed message
in the prosperity theology the idea that
you can donate to a church and in return
you can you know pay off your rent pay
off your credit card that seems
particularly stomach churning and now
this is a message that is being exported
from america to europe and africa so one
of nigeria's wealthiest pastors is this
guy called david oyadepo who is said to
be worth 150 million dollars we are not
asking you to give so the church can be
blessed we're asking you to give so you
can be blessed
some fellows said okay i was what 150
million dollars i said that's an insult
150 million dollars that's an insult 150
million too small
do they know what they're doing
you know a big part of me believes that
copeland and dollar they they truly
believe their intentions are good even
for hundreds of millions of dollars i
can't imagine someone knowingly deceive
and hurt other people without just
driving themselves insane in the long
run like type of cognitive dissonance
just seems too much to bear but at the
end of the day i'm never gonna know what
their intentions are you know i can only
ever see what the consequences of their
actions are and trust me
you haven't seen the worst of it yet
[Music]
benny hinn
hinn is probably most well known for
what he calls his miracle crusades hin
claims to be able to perform miracles
he'll bring people to the stage with all
sorts of illnesses and then with the
touch of his hand they will feel god's
power running through them as they fall
back and these catchers will catch them
as they fall you had parkinson's
for
15 years he says oh thanks for the
anointing who are you people in the
audience will cheer there are others who
are stood there in awe with their hands
raised in worship and benny hinn isn't
the only one that does this right this
is a really common practice amongst the
prosperity gospel circles
glory to god you're not bound to this
chair the day will come you'll walk out
of it
in the name of jesus
what is it that we're really seeing here
is this an actual miracle
i would know
that there were certain things that were
completely deceptive
kostihin is the nephew of benny hinn and
he's worked with his family sometimes as
a catcher himself in 2017 kostihin came
forward with a testimony of his time
spent in benny hinn's ministry the
responsibility is to
look really good look really blessed
sell the narrative make all the money
and say look at my life if you give to
this if you follow it if you obey it and
if you do what i say
god will do it for you too he described
the lifestyle that he had whilst working
with his family we lived in a 10 000
square foot mansion guarded by a private
gate drove two mercedes-benz vehicles
vacationed in exotic destinations and
shopped at the most expensive stores
kostihin
really believed in what he was doing you
know but he only had doubts when he
started finding contradictions in what
he was teaching and what he was finding
in the bible
grace bruhler was eight years old when
she was featured on an episode of cbc's
the fifth estate in 2005 an episode that
was specifically investigating hen's
ministry if you could have a miracle
what would you want it to be
just walk
is that what you want chris just to walk
grace's mother brings her daughter to
one of his miracle crusades and just as
she's about to go to the stage she's
intercepted by what are called screeners
who tell her to step aside according to
that documentary and an insider the job
of the screeners is to screen out the
people that are severely sick and ill
there's the story of justin peters who
is an evangelist himself and was born
with cerebral palsy during the fifth
estate's investigation into hints
ministry they attempt to get peters to
go on stage as well and just like grace
he is also intercepted by the screeners
our hidden camera shows justin being
stopped by a screener watch as henry him
whispers something to her
then justin is told to step aside
in another documentary from 2001 hbo
were given full access to hins events
and were even allowed to follow several
cases of supposed miracle healings these
are people that actually managed to get
onto the stage and claim they'd been
healed in one instance the crew follows
a boy called ashnil and his parents as
they are desperate to have their child
healed by one of his miracles we
expecting miracle we're expecting
america
the prakash family are recent immigrants
to america
ten-year-old ash neal is their younger
son
two massive brain tumors have reduced
him to a vegetative state
we believe in god we have faith
and there's nothing impossible for god
later in the documentary ashnaw's
parents actually attend the crusade and
they're brought on stage to have their
child healed by him himself hin gets the
crowd to raise their hands and then he
places his hands on ashnil's face and
says expect the miracle
dear jesus
the lord's gonna touch you young boy
days after the event and ashnil still
wasn't healed it didn't happen i was not
even discouraged i i know it's god's
plan you know i can stake my life on
pasta many hints words
and god spoke to me last night at the
at the colosseum center where the
crusade was going on and he said
donate him another two thousand dollars
and which i'm going to do it
i'm going to do that recently i watched
an event from kenneth copeland's eagle
mountain church right it's called
miracles on a mountain it's another
miracle healing service and in this
instance it was hosted by this
evangelist called billy burke and at one
point someone is brought out from the
crowd
and i thought
hang on i recognized this guy it was big
nick who for those of you that don't
know was an ex-member of the popular
social media group the vlog squad which
is headed by david dobrik
at the event nick tells billy burke
about his blind eye i'm blind in my uh
left eye as well i know that you told me
that billy then attempts to cure his eye
loosen that
after all the theatrics billy then
starts to wiggle his finger around
and then nothing yet
nothing yet and billy hears that and he
continues like trying to help him and
then when he realizes it doesn't work he
then just tells nick recite chapters of
the bible every night for your eye to be
cured so john chapter nine your
confession starting tonight and every
night you hear me tonight and every
night before you go to bed you ready
i was blind and now i see
and the crowd cheers it's like it's like
the miracle actually happened now it's
been about seven months since that event
took place and i've looked through big
nick's social media account and there's
no indication that his eye is healed
since the event so again what are we
witnessing when we see things like this
[Music]
if we are to believe that these people
aren't just actors which i really don't
think that they are
what is actually happening
consider this if what we're seeing is
really a miracle
why don't these people go to hospitals
and heal people there why do they need
the the lights and the cameras and the
atmosphere and the theatrics to be able
to do what they do in 2011 darren brown
ran this tv special program called
miracles for sale in this special
program darren brown who is this
self-described mentalist and illusionist
takes this ordinary individual called
nathan and attempts to turn him into a
faith healer performing miracles in
front of an audience the idea behind the
program was to expose the fact that what
is happening here are not miracles that
it's just a product of psychology the
power of suggestion and misdirection now
some aspects of faith healing are just
pure trickery a good example of this is
the infamous leg growing trick the
preacher todd white is well known for
walking around the streets and finding
individuals who supposedly have one leg
that is shorter than the other and then
miraculously white will begin to grow
out that person's leg right before our
very eyes in jesus name
left leg i command you grow
right now in jesus name
darren brown teaches nathan to do this
exact trick because it's not a miracle
the leg growing trick is infamously used
by charlatans throughout history in fact
a quick google or youtube search will
demonstrate how it can be done in
several ways one of which involves
shifting the other person's shoes to
make it seem as though a leg is being
grown if you speed up the todd white
clip of him performing this miracle and
you just play it back and forth you can
literally see what todd white is doing
[Music]
a big part of faith healing isn't just
tricks like this in fact a lot of it is
rooted in a deeper part of who we are as
people by the end of darren brown's
special nathan is able to perform in
front of a small audience of believers
and you can see that he too is able to
with just the touch of his hand bring
people to fall back as though they were
touched by god themselves to understand
how nathan who is an ordinary guy versus
benny hinn who claims to be able to
perform miracles can do what they're
doing you have to understand the power
behind what they're creating in their
shows
from the very moment it begins you're
joined by a crowd of people united by a
particular cause or belief there are
those in the crowd who are already in
pain who feel as though something is
missing in their lives when they're
brought together there is a sense of
oneness of wholeness and unity just
think about how powerful crowds can be
and what it's like to be in one
especially when you're all joined by a
united cause you're then brought into
this hypnotic or more specifically a
suggestible and open state
he wants to heal you because he loves
you
you don't have to pay for it
just ask for it the music rises and
falls stirring a wave of experiences and
emotions amongst the crowd then you
begin to create the expectancy for what
is about to come all
things are possible to him that
believeth you keep the crowd in this
heightened aroused state of mind and as
the crowd is ripened for suggestibility
the faith healer acts almost like a
conductor for the orchestra of
experiences that people are going
through a leader amongst a crowd of
people in a hypnotic trance-like state
is something that you cannot
underestimate the psychological effect
of then the healer begins preaching
their message but don't look for the
healing
look for the healer whatsoever you shall
ask
that will i do
the crowd is full of ecstasy the joy in
the audience is a deep feeling as though
you're becoming a new person you're
connecting with that of which is above
you you expect that when the preacher
lays their hand on you or shouts take it
you will feel god's touch with it you've
been suggested and primed to believe
that that is the case and in being so
connected to the crowd around you the
effects of social conformity are bound
to take place in this trance-like state
you go along with what the preacher's
suggestions are you do what you are
expected to do it's no different to what
a stage hypnotist does you know the more
suggestible you are the more belief you
have the easier it becomes and what's
even more interesting is that in this
heightened state of emotions of euphoria
of adrenaline it's very possible to feel
symptoms being alleviated it's possible
even for someone who is in a wheelchair
to momentarily be able to get up and
walk around but what we are really
witnessing is just a moment of mind over
body
the placebo effect is a well-known
phenomenon it's when a patient's
condition changes after receiving a
treatment that by no means should have
changed their condition for example if a
patient expects a pill to do something
and is told by their doctor that it will
help them even if that pill is just a
sugar pill that doesn't do anything it
is possible for your own brain chemistry
to cause effects similar to what
medication might have caused the key
word here is expect because a placebo
effect is mostly theorized to be caused
by our expectations around a given
treatment expectations that we derive
from culture and society that's why a
placebo that is given as an injection
rather than a pill can be more effective
or when you're given two placebo pills
to take every day rather than one it can
also be more effective because
culturally we perceive the latter of
these treatments to have a bigger effect
on us that belief and expectancy can be
so powerful as to have physiological
effects on our body and what more
powerful expectation can somebody have
the one that invokes their very own
belief in a higher spiritual being like
god surrounded by others who share that
very belief what we are seeing is a
placebo this is why you'll never see any
miracle healer or somebody that believes
in the law of attraction be able to do
anything that is beyond a placebo it's
why you'll never see them be able to
restore the limb of an amputee and as
i've watched your healing crusades
am i seeing anything that goes beyond
placebo i have wondered why sometimes
someone comes in
and comes out of a wheelchair
and walks around runs around
and hours later they're back in that
wheelchair again
the problem is however that those who
attend the event and whose problems and
illnesses are not healed at the event or
return after the event start to blame
themselves that for some reason god
didn't want to heal them that they
didn't have enough faith remember ashnil
from the hbo documentary seven weeks
after attending hinn's miracle crusade
expect the miracle he passed away do you
feel in any way that
any hymn has let you down
no
no
did you ever in some of your worst
moments think that you must have done
something wrong in the eyes of god to
deserve this yes
i know there's a generational curse
maybe it originated from me or from my
parents because that curse
lasts for three or four generations who
taught you that
i hate it
from pastor benny
it doesn't square with the bible at all
it's a complete scam it's utter
deception increase your faith
increase your seed and store up
for the future
so that when these tragedies hit on
earth
you will be spared
it is a deception to a degree that i
don't think i've seen before and you
have to sit there and look at this all
and wonder
surely there's justice to this story
right surely somebody takes the fool
surely there's a happy ending to it
surely
in september of 2019
benny hinn comes out with quite the
astonishing announcement and i'm sorry
to say
that prosperity has gone a little crazy
i think it's an offense to the lord it's
an offense to say give a thousand
dollars i think it's offense to the holy
spirit to place a price on the gospel
i'm done with it
any hymn had decided to leave the
prosperity gospel
hallelujah
right one of the best lessons that i
could give to people is say watch what
they go back to watch what they give up
and watch what they go back to
okay so it's time to give to the lord's
work
it's time to sow seed in the lord's work
so god can bless you
and reward you
for us now it's time to give to the
lord's work
because giving guarantees
our financial protection
the problem is once you've generated the
type of following and business and
reputation that hin has
changing your ways becomes almost
impossible and more so because i
genuinely believe that most of these
prosperity preachers
they're not intentionally malicious
they've deceived themselves even till
today i question
is this god or is this just me
the reality is that most of the
preachers that we've mentioned in this
video are continuing their operations
today and when they pass there's going
to be a wave of new prosperity preachers
ready to take their place the message is
an easy one to spread it promises you
health wealth and happiness it makes you
feel good and what's not to love about
that right look at the comment section
below and you're probably not going to
be hard-pressed to find someone
defending hin or copeland or the
prosperity theology overall you'll
probably find people claiming that they
have seen miracles happen or that by
sowing their seed prosperity really was
given to them and i'm not delivering any
new message here you know prosperity
theology receives a lot of criticism
inside of christianity and outside hey
man you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
right
you know right
yeah they'll still get away with their
teachings because their message isn't
for people who are cynical
it's really difficult to stop their more
deceptive actions the only thing you can
do is go to those that believe in it and
steer them away and until that happens
the booming business of prosperity
theology and faith healing will continue
to flourish
[Music]
i don't know what you feel about the
prosperity gospel
the health wealth and prosperity gospel
but i'll tell you what i feel about it
hatred
it is not the
gospel and it's being exported from this
country to africa and asia
selling a bill of goods to the poorest
of the poor
believe this message
your pigs won't die
your wife won't have miscarriages
you have rings on your fingers and coats
on your back
that's coming out of america
the people that ought to be giving our
money
john piper is just one of the many
preachers and ministries that actively
try and combat the prosperity gospel and
although texas is home to some of the
biggest mega churches it's also home to
the trinity foundation a leading
watchdog ministry founded by ollie
anthony that carries out investigations
into some of the conducts of the biggest
televangelists it was only anthony
founder of the east dallas homeless
ministry trinity foundation who
masterminded the investigation and
helped expose some of the top
televangelists in the country
you know faith and religion are powerful
things
seeing the sense of hope that it can
fill a person with or the community and
the purpose that it can inspire towards
good causes i don't think anyone can
look at those things on their own and
say they're bad a few months ago i had
burnt out from working and when that
happened i felt very cynical about
everything that i was doing you know
what was the point and what helped was
having a sense of hope that those
feelings would come to pass and finding
purpose in what i was doing and spending
time with my friends and family hope
purpose and community but hope purpose
and community can be exploited it can
cloud your better judgment just because
somebody dresses the part or sounds the
part and invokes the word god if you're
somebody watching this that is a
believer in the prosperity gospel i
invite you to think over and really
question could i be wrong a healthy
skepticism i think only motivates
someone to find the truth not drift
further away from it seek
and perhaps you will find
if you think the world of prosperity
preachers and mega churches is crazy
then my friends you have to check out my
documentary on new age gurus it should
be shown somewhere on the screen that is
arguably where all of this kind of began
to form and originate and it is just a
whole other rabbit hole in and of itself
but either way my friends it is great to
be back as always hand to head salute
you